so last week the cdc whose instructions
we followed to the letter
on all things issued a statement that
wasn't about covetous about chickens and
they warned americans don't get too
close to your chicken stop
chicken touching we never even heard of
chicken touching so this being a news
program we immediately sought a chicken
enthusiast to
explain and we found her name is tara
solomon she came on friday night
here's part of the interview are these
house birds i mean i'm trying not to ask
do they sleep on the bed but i'll just
ask do they sleep on the bed
so when i have like chicks when i've
hatched chicks
i have been known to bring them inside
i'll like roll them up in a towel
and they'll sleep next to me and it will
be like a chicken burrito
and sometimes they'll come inside like
if i need to give them a bath or clean
them or stuff but
they're pretty comfortable inside
so we'll be honest we went into this
interview with low expectations you
interview a lot of people on a show like
this and
a chicken enthusiast it's probably kind
of a freaky person right she sleeps with
her chicken
by the end of that interview we were 100
percent on her side and the side of
any chicken enthusiast who loves her
chickens and we heard from a lot of them
including a lady who paints her chickens
nails i think we have video of that we
can put on the screen
we are not putting this on tv to mock
that may have been our intention friday
but no longer
in a time of sadness and alienation
animals are a blessing from god they
give us comfort they give us joy
being with them even if they're chickens
is worthwhile
not maybe as great as a spaniel but
still
we're totally in favor of it so thank
you chicken lady for changing our mind
completely
that's about it for us tonight don't
forget our new episode of tucker carlson
today is
on fox nation we hope you like it we'll
be back
tomorrow night and every weeknight the
show that is the sworn enemy
of lying pomposity smugness and
groupthink our new documentary series dr
carlson originals
also on fox nation have a great evening
sean hannity right now
i now know what i'm going to get you for
christmas a chicken you can pet and kiss
perfect did you whatever whatever you
need thank you so i'm happy
i will buy you a chicken a pet chicken
all right tucker thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else